this is uh episode 12 just one more
after this uh male what a nice just a
good episode I only know what to say I'm
just getting so invested alas poor
Yorick I knew him well hey is it the
horrible to say that you feel more bad
bad no because now is amazing that was
that you're like I'm the one that you
know it's kind of like but it's kind of
like when Ed left and cowboy bebop on
the one hand I'm like oh no Bobby ever
hand I'm like no that it feels right
that's just that's the way they have
sugar I must return to my home planet I
just wanted to do like you know like the
camera turns like she just does a spin
jump in there like a bird catches her
and she flies off
I was I was waiting for her to just like
raise her arms and then just ascend to
this guy into a UFO like no she do
something cooler like I said she do like
some sort of flute or something
you know I'd like you know the birds of
the world but she's so cool I know some
place considerably further at you where
she talking I you know what good
question good question
I don't know for sure um the theory is
that she is the crane mother which was
from iron fist which I am not that
familiar with because I didn't read it I
believe most of this is more fairly
recently but yeah apparently there was
like there's these heavenly cities and
she's from there was a Kundu nor cooler
heavenly cities you mean like BioShock
Infinite where they're just cities in
the clouds or and I believe another
ascension idea if you want my honest
opinion knowing what little I know about
it it reminds me a lot of Mortal Kombat
I got this impression that it's like
another room and there literally is like
this kind of Mortal Kombat thing that
one guy didn't want to participate in
she got pissed off about it
resurrect
some other guy to hunt this guy down got
involved in Hydra and stuff like that's
about all I know and one of the guys she
wrecked resurrected his steel serpent
and what she stamps on the drugs is also
his symbol or something so there's all
this talk like who crossover and there's
gonna be an iron fist show and I am fist
is the guy yes bullseye he shows up a
trader I I don't know but the the guess
is that it's cream mother and honestly
it's the only one that makes the most
sense to me because she's she obviously
she took Murtagh out would like she's
like yeah fuck you and like she just he
was like oh oh yeah
so she seems to have like almost a
supernatural power
she speaks God knows how many languages
and then yeah she says I I must return
you know and he's like China a
considerably farther distance and she's
like it was never about the heroin than
it was so she's got some other thing
maybe she's trying to lure iron fists
that like I'm guessing she's the crane
mother which if she's the crane mother
at least if she transforms into the
crane mother will be kind of cool
because if you ever seen images of
accountings like tall it could be cool I
don't know that better that is the full
extent of my knowledge on that mister no
yeah no I know that's just a guess cuz I
don't believe she went by Madame Gao in
the comics I think people are just
guessing well it's the grandmother I
hope so
but either way I hope she comes back you
know there's it the fight thing is
thinking back to this episode I was like
man that was really good then when I
turn the record button on I was kind of
like wait what exactly happen cuz I just
remember being really good but then like
I mare these moments but like if you
were to say yeah what actually happened
when was the connecting story in this I
remember scenes and moments but and even
and I do even remember sort of like
themes - a - but like in terms of like
one continuous story I don't think of
that one that in this one
much and they I swore would I like more
about it it's almost like a shits going
on but it's also kind of a mellow one
too but it's also really intense way if
I know it a lot in a lot ways again I've
said this the deep Gus before yeah like
it's almost like we're kind of setting
up for the final act and it's yeah it is
cuz stuff does happen he takes out the
Triad in the heroin trade
they all the blind people all attack him
and the reporter gets killed Gao
disappears
yeah it's the outfit is still being made
oh and and Fisk has a touching goodbye
to Wesley in the beginning of the
episode yeah I was him their bromance
your likes it's of nexuiz
high you feel bad that like yeah I'm his
girlfriend wakes up from her poison
dream whatever and yeah vanessa is back
so I was half right once half right
another time but not completely right
because I should just get both of them
and that was go and patch Adams guy
legally I was gonna call the Pancham guy
um so ya know that's something where
it's like cuz we didn't you hear him
talk he and then it's like no I talked
to her yeah she doesn't know anything
I'm like well clearly they would have
shown that scene if they really wanted
to convince us obviously I had seen this
before it so I didn't do but my initial
guess was gal because she pretty much
spelled it out to him from the beginning
you will have to choose our fate will
choose for you that way she's saying I'm
just gonna make you do what I want
he's gonna say when they weren't showing
her you think it was her and then they
were accusing her it's like well it's
either not her or it can't just be her
it OC to me I'm just like well it's her
that's why they're not showing her but
but see then I was convinced it was
patch Adams guy and what they can he was
in on it but he wasn't
he's that conniving enough to do it
himself you know it's fine I just went a
bought bed he would have liked the
neighborhood
this whole thing together he was the
character that annoyed me the most to
start off and I bet he was a complainer
we just really grown on me actually
especially in these last few episodes -
get your hands off me he called me
always the one that everybody stuck away
from pain I'm supposed to be here
you know the the opening with her going
to her apartment and then seeing 50 well
first I said this is a dream this is
obviously a dream but it'd be so cool if
it wasn't and then we get that scene at
the end anyway it's that time about that
scene it's a great setup for the ending
so that there's almost a part of you
like hoping is this just another dream
is you're just drunk like no no it's
real and again it's all about the
balance Fisk loses Wesley now they lose
Urich yeah it's is it always has to even
out somehow but there's always you have
to pay for your sins
speaking of which they're seeing in a
second time there is one thing I really
noticed which is what what was it that
the Italian mobster said when he left at
the beginning when he was talking to
Urich he says I'm getting the hell out
of Dodge at this event and he said you
know you know I've been in prison for a
lot of years and that but out of all the
newspaper reporters that reported on
what I did you were the only one who
didn't bring my kids into it
you've left my family out of it and like
it wasn't lost on me that at the very
end why does your it get killed
you brought my mother interested you
know it's like he broke kind of that one
rule and that again it's very Catholic
concept yeah this concept of somehow you
have to pay for one this are the Italian
mafia thing that's like you know the
family the family it's like you know you
don't they're sort of that unspoken Oh
in spoken role about like you don't mess
with the family and you know like I'm
sure they do you know oh yeah but I mean
that's I think it's like Europe had this
sort of it seemed like this unofficial
rule that the other guy was grateful to
him for and it's like he broke the rule
once and look what
yeah um yeah I was gonna say that being
said I'm surprised that they did that
because I'm pretty sure he's still alive
in the Marvel comic oh well I was gonna
say if they bring spider-man into the
Marvel Universe with the Avengers and
stuff like that clearly he's not gonna
be in that I know he was in the
spider-man
well that's all yeah he was in
spider-man he was one of those crossover
characters he worked they created a new
paper for this he would be working for
the bugle
Parker's paper but it all I can figures
this was pre signing that deal with Sony
so they just figured well we're never
gonna really have I don't know maybe
they just figured they were never gonna
have the rights to it or they didn't
know what to do but yeah I was kind of
surprised because I'm like huh I'm like
there's an interesting major character
you just killed off wait the the two
scenes that like hey kind of free
emotional it seems to me what is the
opening when she goes to her home and
it's like showering and stuff like then
you just feel you feel that way that she
killing a person there's a realism to to
reactions because I swear to God the
second she pops open like the bottle of
whiskey and this is like oh this is like
that is exactly what I need sleeping
with like the shades drawn and the light
shining through and it's very dark in
there and stuff I mean it's like there
is this realism that there's a movie
called in the bedroom that tried to
capture the same realism and I if long
as movies I cannot explain why for me I
mean it's I'm sure it because I love our
people but for some reason they're
trying to capture us and didn't work for
me and they spend so much time on it I
try to do it so well and it's they spend
as long about this movie trying to
capture this and I really appreciate the
effort but so fight within like a few
minutes that they captured it in this
opening and but that could be we can
have shown to know this character is
well my - I think it just they captured
that retreat from the world there was
almost like yeah actor cellphone close
the drapes drink yourself take a shower
almost everything there everything she's
doing is almost just like maybe it did
but maybe it's all a bad dream maybe you
know just like yeah taking a shower like
trying to get clean this I'm either just
you almost feel that feeling in your
stomach when you know you're watching us
like man you just when this show always
had a good sense of dread even going
into Eurex death before that like I cuz
I didn't think they were gonna kill your
cough at the same time I didn't think
they would kill Karen I'm either but I
was looking at the way that scene was
set up with Karen and I'm just like are
they gonna attack her or something cuz
she sits there at the desk and did you
know that he knows so there's this sense
of dread throughout half the episode
like what is Fisk gonna do like cuz the
setting this whole thing up and she
shows up at your ex places like we need
to get the story on now there's this
sense of like panic and just do it at
any second we can be killed and the show
really knows how to ratchet up like that
kind of terror factor that dread like
any second now somebody behind you is
gonna take you out because you know too
much the other two that I thought were
really effective one is when one fits as
crazy and twists as they are it's like a
really by their chemist yeah I really do
I mean it's like if I could redo the top
11 strangest romantic couples like I put
them on there on the list
and then the other I really liked seeing
a Murdock breakdown and say I really I
can't do this I can't do this alone and
then he really sold it I really felt
like it felt like he was really breaking
down and really just he was starting to
crumble and she was there to help him
and stuff and I thought that was a
really legitimately good emotional scene
again there's an interesting dichotomy
because what he just came out of was
witnessing a bunch of people who had
literally blind faith that they were
gonna get something better and it's all
just kind of a scam you know so that we
know of
maybe the well I mean crazy you know um
but I think that's the point from his
point of view he's just like my god can
it get any worse than this you know and
it I think it challenged his faith and
then he's right like I can't do this
alone
like I I fuckin seen rock bottom now
like Jesus Christ how can this get and
then they blinded themselves
yeah and they blinded themselves of that
and for someone who never
to be blind himself you know it wasn't a
B there's a bunch of people that chose
to do it because they still thought
because I'm Vader the very thing yeah
fucking but gambling with from yeah come
on this shit is really really good um so
you know and maybe that's why we were
talking about the religious stuff in the
past maybe that's why I have such a
respect for when they do talk about the
religious aspects constants isn't just
hey religion is good religious go to
religions bad religions bad it's showing
both sides and it's saying you can draw
your own conclusion but we're gonna look
at this intelligently the pros and cons
of faith and religion well and you know
and try to make and cuz that's really
where the epic size of something these
stories that do involve religion and
faith come from it does come from with a
night you believe or don't believe and
not just believe good not believe bad
you know or vice versa
it's the complications it's in betweens
the gray area and I think this show so
covers even with heroes and villains it
still covers that gray area so well
there was a line in the previous episode
I forgotten about but I think it sums up
how they treat religion in this and it's
she says you said this city needs you I
think the city just as much created you
and I love the use of Catholicism in
this film and religion in this film
because there is this kind of like is it
faith creating the person or does the
person kind of create the faith are both
like all for all characters in this they
all have these like ideologies and this
this faith and the zealot wreath at what
they're doing maybe right you know wrong
or whatever but it's like is it chicken
its chicken or the egg it's like which
came first
like does Murdoch's faith come out of
something deeper that was there to begin
with or is it a reaction to you know
growing up in this hellhole
same thing with Fisk I think you know
and there have been a lot of finality
you know there's obviously phenomenal
scholars out there and there's
phenomenal preachers and stuff like that
and there's films that do this kind of
stuff this challenging stuff I mean I'll
be free I have thought much more
seriously about like faith and what it
means and all that stuff in this show
that I really have for you know right
and I
it's because when you go in when you do
hear a preacher or a previous no matter
how good they are there or something
not on the ones out there I mean just
like hats off to you I mean phenomenal
speakers and holy people but I think
there is something about going into the
story where with them you know it's like
well I'm gonna try and convince you of
this and I'm gonna try to be as true to
myself and realistic myself that's what
the great speakers do at the same time
with this their match it doesn't feel
like they're trying to convince anybody
of anything their job they're presenting
you about something yeah they're
presenting not so much high points of
views you know pro or con yeah and con
it's very ambiguous and grey and that's
why it works
yeah it's not I don't find it over like
and I don't find it overtly Pro
religious I don't find it romantic
religious either it's just like here's
the different interpretations of what
you got like here's our dinner plate of
like various beliefs on religion and how
it applies to good and evil and you
figure it out yeah enjoy the meal
it has the respect to the audience to
let you draw your own conclusion and ya
know what else to say it's just it's
it's so well done it's hard to believe
we're down to the final episode now and
I'm definitely excited why the fuck we
still talking let's watch it
but no more Madame Gao they're there
they're trained thing I'm sure she'll be
back
I don't know about Leland though